what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime orpro and today I will be
breaking down and explaining the stern
RIT from Bleach weakest to strongest the
stern Rit are immensely powerful Quincy
debuting during bleach's 1,000 year
blood warar Arc the stern Rit are formed
up of 27 very powerful Quincy each with
strength equivalent to or more than a
captain of the Soul Society each of
these Stern Ritter have experienced at
right in which they drank UA's blood the
man whom they all worship as if he were
their God now after consuming UA's blood
he would carve a letter containing a
portion of his own soul into the Quincy
bestowing that Stern RIT with special
skills and talents known as shifts and
these guys are certainly no joke but who
is the strongest of all of them well we
will be diving into the strongest of the
bunch starting from the weakest to the
strongest in order to answer that very
question so make sure to stick around
till the very end now if you do enjoy
these bleach videos on the channel and
you'd like to see more you know what to
do smash that like button it really
helps us out with that algorithm and if
you haven't already make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications we are so very close to
hitting the amazing Milestone of 2
million subscribers here on the channel
so every subscription counts and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all coming in dead last and
the weakest of all the sternritter is
definitely barones his shrift is called
the question the question allows barones
to injure their opponents by opposing to
their existence or actions however other
than that we don't really know much
about his skills or abilities what we do
know is that Baron's power does not work
if he is unable to fully speak and is
also ineffective against those who can't
fully hear him talking so for someone
whose power depends on the sound of
their own voice and their opponent's
ability to listen having your throat
torn out by a Brute Force such as Kachi
is going to render you completely
powerless which was exactly the case for
barones unlucky bro second on today's
list is Jerome who despite being a total
monster didn't really get a chance to
shine at all to be honest his shrift is
called the Roar the roar allows Jerome
to grow even bigger than he currently is
and gives him a more aplike appearance
in this form he can greatly boost the
energy of his Roars causing massive
devastating shock waves to hurdle
towards his opponents this ability has
been shown to be far more powerful on
the Lesser ranked Soul Reapers
mutilating and even killing some
although the the raw isn't all that
effective against higher ranking Soul
Reapers such as Kachi who was only
momentarily deafened by this ability so
yeah his Roar was so loud that it
drowned out barones and led to his death
at the hands of Kachi but like mentioned
because Jerome's raw only briefly
deafened Kachi he was then easily taken
out by the captain so yeah definitely
not going any higher than this on the
list next up we have Lloyd roid Lloyd's
younger brother who also has the same
letter designation Y which stands for
the yourself roid actually places higher
up on this list so we will dive more
into their ability when we get to him
but in a nutshell the power allows them
to mimic others in terms of their
appearance and abilities Lloyd is one of
the first to be sent out and engaged in
combat in the ark he impersonated
individuals in order to pass himself off
as Kachi now the real Kachi however
easily dispatched uh Lloyd and brought
the bodies of yes Lloyd Jerome and
barones to UA basically to Glow so yet
he didn't really have any time to shine
here at all so he places here on the
list neonz is up next with his shrift
called the wind the wind sometimes known
as twist and turns is an ability that
allows him to deflect assaults away from
certain targets however this power only
allows him to divert strikes rather than
oppon them yet it is still a very
amazing ability that has led swords to
bend away from their intended targets
pretty awesome now the wind may be
utilized offensively and can be quite
damaging by shifting his finger in the
direction of his opponent he can induce
the wind to cut his chosen Target in two
by causing each opposing end to bend
away from itself neon is someone who
gets to show off his powers early in the
Thousand-Year blood War Arc the problem
is is that he wasn't quick enough to
counter strikes from senum Maru and was
pierced with spikes yeah ouch so for
that reason he places pretty low on the
list next up is bg9 he has the
designation of K though we don't know
what the k stands for nor the power that
it has given him he is essentially a
cybernetic person with the mind of a
supercomputer his Spirit weapon though
is a gigantic 10 Barrel min that
unleashes devastating blast we also know
that he has a vult standing but again we
don't know what that does so
unfortunately we didn't really see a lot
of what he had to offer he counters soyo
and shunko but he does lose that 10
Barrel minigun in the process and while
he did see soy phone's bonkai it was
stolen again and soy phone severely
damaged him before he was killed by uar
and jugram so unfortunately for him this
as far as he goes
moving on to najak coup whose power was
called the underbelly the underbelly
also known as defenseless is an ability
that enables him to examine the Riu of a
specified Target for a certain period of
time he can assess that person's Spirit
Force distribution here and will imprint
his letter on his Target in a grid that
he can locate holes in and Target their
ratu and then assault them rendering
them unconscious or paralyzed the
strength of this ability is entirely
dependent on how much time he has spent
researching certain Riu the more time he
has the more powerful his ability
becomes and though ranking the guy who
not only escaped yamamoto's Flames with
bby's assistance but also disabled Eisen
this low you could consider kind of
controversial but it is for a cause
despite these accomplishments he is
defeated by byakuya and later gutted
down by his own part partner BBY this is
all after attempting to get revenge on
shunu Kuro as well so yeah he's still
impressive of course but compared to the
others on this list yeah he definitely
has his own limits next up we have Candi
catnip and boy yeah I won't lie to you
here I do wife this one no shame at all
and you know again it's a real shame
that she didn't rank higher but if it
was for niceness she'd definitely be top
but anyway candi's catnip is the most
hot-headed of the bambas she is obsessed
with her attractiveness and dresses
provocatively so you can see why I like
her right again no shame so candies as
the name implies has the ability to
produce and manipulate lightning she
frequently manipulates and creates these
lightning bolts in her hands before
directing the assault in the desired
direction of her opponent she can also
summon tremendous lightning assaults
from the sky to strike her opponent now
not only can she utilize lightning to
fight but she can also use it to evade
assaults by transforming her body into
lightning so her spirit weapon is a bow
with a heart shape at the center she can
shoot Str strong holy Arrows with
lightning Jagged edges from this bow and
if she so desires she can even launch
electrical blasts from the bow Candy's V
standing is of course electricity base
as you'd imagine her wings are six
lightning bolts sprouted from from her
back which allow her to fly through the
air she also has lightning swords which
are the same lightning bolts on her back
she practically takes them off her back
and has one in each hand these swords
are excellent for close battle but she
can also transform them into javelins by
tossing them making her as formidable at
long range fighting too candies also
possesses electrical destruction
punishment in which she conjures a
massive column of electrical energy
around her she concentrates it around
her arm and then throws it at her
opponent so yeah candies was as
hot-headed as they come and because of
this she was thoroughly defeated like
completely totaled despite her amazing
electric powers she is flung around by
Ichigo she loses an arm and is easily
taken down by biia off screen the only
thing she can take credit for is
defeating Kachi but he was already weak
at the time but yeah I still would
though she's nice 20th Place on the list
goes to sangu whose shrift is called the
iron the iron is a power that allows him
to wrap his entire body in iron and he
is able to cover only certain sections
of his skin or his full body if he
chooses to the iron is extremely strong
and durable as you'd expect and it can
survive even the most powerful strikes
not only is this a fantastic defensive
ability but it can also be employed
offensively too he can charge straight
at his opponent while covered in Iron
delivering a powerful knockout blow on
impact now a pair of RI claws serve as
his Spirit weapon he wears four
incredibly powerful curved blades on
each of his wrists and he also employs
the snake claw technique in which he
aims his arm at his opponent and Crosses
one hand over the other in doing so he
fires energy blasts that resemble the
head of a snake to his opponent he also
had a vult standing but we don't know
much about it other than it was powerful
enough to break him free from the ice
prison that Captain hea had confined him
in sang du was certainly an interesting
character one who started off really
well but everything turned sour for him
pretty quick sangu had the chance to
shine after successfully ambushing
mamoto before facing heat Zaya the issue
is that he spent too much time chatting
away way and getting cocky and was
defeated by heaya before he barely
deployed his signature iron skin ability
and thus his fate was sealed here of
course as despite his attempts to fight
back he is slain by dram for his failure
Driscoll is next up on the list Driscoll
is one of the most unpleasant and
bloodthirsty of the sternritters in
Bleach the dude is an absolute monster
having killed over 200 Soul Reapers upon
his first appearance and his shrift is a
pretty cool one too called the overkill
Driscoll's Overkill ability offers him a
rise in power each time that he kills an
opponent it's kind of like a kill streak
like thing the more he kills regardless
of the opponent the stronger he grows
his Spirit weapon is a pair of Teo bands
that he wears on his hands and from
which he can launch Holy arrows his
arrows if you can call them that are
enormous in size he is so massive that
he throws his arrows like javelins his
throws have remarkable power so much so
that they can easily dispatch a typical
Shinigami the guy is an absolute brute
his highlight I guess you could say is
when he killed sasakibe at long range
and also knocked hisagi out too his
overconfidence like many a bad guy was
of course his downfall he thought he
could take on Captain Commander Yamamoto
so he was however Incorrect and was
burned to ashes as a result so yeah I'm
sorry but that was never going to end
well for him and it didn't next up we
have Pepe who has a really kind of nasty
ability when you think about it the
ability or shrift is called the love the
love is an ability that allows him to
send a heart-shaped missile at his
opponents by forming his own hands into
a heart you know that really Kawaii hand
gesture anyone who is hit by this
missile falls in love with him and
becomes so enchanted with him that they
would do anything and everything that he
asks of them including assaulting their
own comrades he also has a move called
love kiss that works similarly to the
last one in that he brings his hands
together in the shape of a heart and
shoots a projectile but this projectile
is similar to that of a regular attack a
holy bow is his weapon his bow is Tiny
and has a strong handle which he will
reveal by drawing it out of his mouth he
also manifests the Arrow by drawing that
out of his mouth as well which is um
let's say interesting now God's love is
the name given to his V standing he
triggers his V standing by creating a
heart shape in the air with his hands
and his metamorphis transforms him into
a very unappealing Cupid looking thing
his Vol stand in abilities include
increased durability flying and a love
rope technique in which he manifests a
floating basket with many ropes made up
of connected Hearts he then throws these
ropes at his opponent who become fully
immobilized after being stabbed by him
so yeah Pepe was certainly a very
interesting character he did seize
control of hisagi as well as his comrade
menus he also gained control of byya zok
toe but was halted before completing the
task and was eventually eaten by Lil
Toto for attacking his
friends 17th spark goes to Robert
acutron Robert was one of the smartest
and most non-nonsense sternritters in
bleach and his major strength was his
speed Robert was the sternritter with
the letter n as his designation
unfortunately we do not know what the
letter n stands for nor do we know what
its powers were what we do know is that
that Robert's Spirit weapon is a Ry
pistol that resembles a handgun and is
capable of creating muzzle flashes he
can also shoot holy arrows or bullets
from the muzzle of its gun which despite
its small size has a tremendous amount
of devastating Force his V standing is
named God step and he has bestowed a
variety of Ry accessories including
wings that offer him the power of flying
while also substantially increasing his
own speed now despite the lack of
information on Robert his place is
certainly not under question he was able
to catch shunu curo off guard shattering
one of his eyes and was able to survive
a cut from shunu despite the pain and
damage that it caused Robert himself
survived until the last battle when he
was defeated by byya and eventually
murdered by
UA another absolute babe of a character
up next is yes men men was the second of
the female sternritters and possibly one
of the most physically powerful menas is
a courteous perhaps even kind
sternritter with a particular skill that
appears to contradict her outward
appearance you know her pink hair frilly
skirt and gloves leg warmers adorable
voice and peaceful demeanor appear to be
in Striking contrast to the brutality
with which she murders her foes what
sticks out about menus is how she
appears dizzy yet becomes visibly upset
when she is
underestimated now her shrift is called
the power and her power is that of
superhuman strength her strikes are
incredibly lethal due to her brute
strength and force along with this menas
can easily pick up and hurl very massive
structures and if she so desires she can
substantially expand the size of her own
muscles even more more if she is in need
of more power so a bow is her spirit
weapon her bow is also kept in a little
heart container on her belt all of the
arrows she launches from her bows have
these heart-shaped tips many Nas's V
standing grants her wings allowing her
to S at high speeds her wings are
constructed from Big heart-shaped parts
and though her powers aren't as flashy
as some of the others on this list many
of those others have applauded her super
human power and she has certainly backed
up this praise as we have seen her lift
large buildings with just a single hand
and then there's the fact that she
nearly murdered Rukia in her debut she
also knocked Kachi unconscious with a
single blow and landed a clean shot on
ich go you simply can't ignore this cuti
strength next up is Opie who is the
exective hunting Captain whose shrift
was called the jail the jail enables op
to use Ry structures to shut the portals
between realities he could also use this
power to construct Ry cages that
imprison and entangle his opponents now
when a person is caught within one of
his Ry cages their existence is sealed
off from the outer world and cannot be
recognized they can hear everyone's
voices outside of the cage but they
can't understand them now op Spirit
weapon is a Ry sword resembling a milit
saber these arrows are strong enough to
cause explosions upon impact and he may
fire up to six at once his V standing is
Bisal which is Japanese for God's
justice in this form Opie gains an array
of Ry based accessories including boots
gauntlets a sword that emerges from his
right hand and of course a pair of
angelic looking Wings his V standing
grants him the ability to fly increase
spiritual awareness Ness increase speed
and perfect RI domination letting him
absorb vast amounts of RI and mold it
into a tremendous assault from the point
of his sword Opie also possesses the
ability holy slave which allows him to
harvest RI by enslaving it he can absorb
RI from spiritual items and transform it
into his own taking on the attributes
and talents of his victims in the
process now Opie was the first truly
difficult encounter for Ichigo in the
bleach Thousand-Year blood War Arc Opie
didn't waste any time in demonstrating
how he was able to Simply destroy or
otherwise prevent more than a few people
from reaching the soul Society after
absorbing aan however for all of this it
really didn't stop green Jael from
severing him clean in half still a very
impressive Stone Ritter with some very
truly unique and interesting abilities
nonetheless 14th Place and just missing
out on the top half of the most powerful
sternritter goes to Lil Toto Lil Toto is
arguably bleach his smallest character
despite her tiny stature and childlike
demeanor her shrift has the potential to
be one of the most terrifying called the
Glutton when translated the Glutton or
gluttonous ability allows Lil Toto to
swallow anything by manipulating and
moving her own mouth into its enlarged
shape her mouth expands into a massive
jaw with numerous Jagged fangs that she
can manipulate to consume whatever she
wants the disadvantage of her power is
that it causes her to be constantly
hungry and we saw her use this
terrifying power on many unidentified
11th Squad officers decapitating them
all at once gluttony is frequently
recognized as one of the seven deadly
sins one of the Seven Sins that develop
as a poisonous deformity of basic
characteristics in humans like we
mentioned with her weakness the Glutton
ability appears to have cursed little
Toto with the Affliction of a bottomless
pit for her stomach since she is
continuously seen eating what's
interesting is her seeming lack of
emotional range might be a projection of
the concept that gluttony can develop
from a wish to fill a deep and profound
vacuum inside on I always find it really
interesting how anime can portray these
things like the seven deadly sins and
things of that nature and it's it's done
very well in Lil Toto's character if you
look into it a bit deeper now back to
her power Lil Toto's Spirit weapon is a
small holy bow that she keeps in a heart
container that she wears on her belt her
bow Bears a heart at its core with two
arms branching out from it the bow is
really shaped like a closed pair of jaws
with sharp teeth similar to a bear trap
her holy arrows from her bow are
extremely strong when she FS an arrow
from her bow the Jaws on her bow open
her vult standing bestowed upon her two
small teeth like wings they're pretty
cute her wings provide her obviously the
capacity to fly at tremendous speeds
after consuming Pepe she obtained his
powers and she utilized them to great
success in attempting to rescue her
comrades however UA simply cast her
aside when she and the others tried to
betray him Unlucky 13 some might say and
the halfway point in this list 13th spot
goes to gasel who is arguably the most
powerful female sternritter in Bleach
however I think there is one more just
above her she has black hair with
antenna like protrusions that give her
the appearance of like a cockroach she
acts weak and has this silly disposition
about her since she has yet to take
anything seriously however gasel is the
sternritter with one of the most scary
powers she was dubbed shrift Z the
zombie by uarm this ability allows her
to control her adversaries by using her
blood which she can utilize after
tempting an opponent into attacking her
power is a control-based one in which
anything and anybody splattered with her
blood is entirely under her control the
more powerful the opponent she wishes to
influence the more blood she must drop
on that specific Target those under her
command become corpses and she makes
command them to perform her bidding the
zombie's power however does not operate
on other Quincy unless that Quincy has
previously died when it comes to the
Quincy gazelle may call the bodies of
deceased Quincy whenever she wants and
activate their skills remotely in the
hands of any villain the power to
manipulate the living and the dead is a
devastating one and nonetheless
gazelle's execution of her abilities are
both comic and Eerie as shown during
during her battle against Ichigo gazelle
also has an intriguing and perhaps
terrifying healing technique in which
she can Leverage The zomes abilities to
heal her companions by swapping their
deceased flesh or limbs with those of
the Dead her spirit weapon consists of a
small bow with a heart in the center to
reflect her zombie Motif the limbs that
Branch out of the bow are skeleton like
she of course uses her bow to fire
strong Arrows with skull tips finally
gazelle's V standing gave her skeletal
Ry wings and gifted her the ability of
fly overall gazelle is a very unique
character and I really like the concept
of her powers if used correctly it is
without a doubt very very
op moving on to the strongest female
sternritter and the self-proclaimed
leader of the bambies yes bambietta
bambietta wasn't only explosive in the
ls department but also in terms of her
power quite literally I may say cuz
Bambi's shrift was called the explode
the explode which is Japanese meaning
bombing rain is an ability that allows
bambietta to make explosives or bombs
rain down on her enemies these aren't
true RI bombs but Rishi that transforms
whatever it comes into touch with into
bombs implying that her attacks are
pretty much unblockable she can Target
not just particular foes but also wide
areas unleashing massive amounts of
catastrophic damage bambietta can also
produce explosive energy in the form of
a big sphere around herself now bambata
has the ability to change concentrated
RI into weapons although her preferred
Spirit weapon is a RI blade that
resembles a broadsword Bamba's V
standing bestows upon her the power to
fly through huge Ry Wings allowing her
to Glide in the air at very high speeds
her Vol standing also improves the
explode by releasing Ry orbs from
beneath These Wings by doing so she can
generate a big number of these orbs
covering a larger region anything that
comes into touch with these Ry orbs
turns into an explosive that explodes
almost instantaneously bambietta was a
true force to be reckoned with she is
the most explosive no pun intended of
the female Stone ritters and is regarded
as their leader even if self-proclaimed
of course she had the most power of all
and was able to push and stall a number
of opponents including Hina Mori komura
and
others next up we have a guy with a
fiery disposition a hot-headed attitude
and yeah fire abilities that is of
course the awesome BBY whose shrift is
the heat the Heat or searing heat is the
capacity to manufacture flames and fire
them at his opponents by controlling the
ri in the air these Flames are so
intense that they successfully countered
yamamoto's riin shaka's Flames which is
an insane feat he possesses a variety of
abilities including burner finger one
which allows him to blast a short beam
of fire from his finger BBY concentrates
the force of his Flames into two of his
fingers in Bur a finger 2 then he swings
his fingers causing a massive explosion
of cat atrophic destruction burner
finger 3 is where he creates heat in
three of his fingers causing whatever
structure he touches with his fingertips
to erupt into lava with Burner finger
for BBY points all of his fingers
forward he creates a broad blade of fire
he can then employ this flaming blade to
cut his opponent triggering enormous
explosions when he creates fire around
all five of his fingertips or four
fingers one thumb however you want to
see it he unleashes is burning full
fingers a spiraling cone of flame
finally when he Stomps his foot on the
ground he emits a great amount of heat
and Flames a move that he calls burning
stomp now his V standing grants him two
Wings in the shape of two rods he can
fly at fast speeds through the air due
to These Wings his V standing also
considerably increases his own speed
allowing him to strike his opponents
before they have a chance to retaliate
BBY was a very fearsome opponent who was
more than capable of holding his own in
less than a minute he was able to take
out four of the top seats in the third
division he also got the upper hand on
heaya albeit he was interrupted BBY was
maybe a little too hot-headed for his
own good as he was so arrogant that he
attempted to battle jugram and gave him
a decent fight but before being killed
epic character but unfortunately one
that just falls short of the top top 10
of the strongest Stern Ritter which yes
we are moving to now top 10 time baby oh
yes number 10 we have mask de masculine
the sternritter with the letter S as his
designation which stands for the
Superstar so yeah don't let the Luchador
mask deceive you here guys as this dude
is certainly one opponent that is not to
be taken lightly at all masculine has
taken out some pretty tough customers
himself such as renji akaku Yumi hisagi
and Rose masculine was able to block
kensei's bonkai with just one hand and
then went on to defeat rose with just a
single attack the dude is an absolute
monster when it comes to his strength
his shrift the Superstar is also
something pretty amazing too having at
least one supporter gives him a
significant increase in strength and
stamina giving him the ability to take
on two Captain leveled Soul Reapers and
knocking them out with just a single
blow as of course we had just mentioned
not only does his strength and stamina
receive a boost but he also gains more
durability and regeneration abilities
and when there are loud enough Applause
his mask transforms giving him a pro
wrestler appearance that significantly
increases his strength star PowerUp is
what he calls it and kind of reminds me
of Mario staying on that topic one thing
you can't deny about masculine is that
he prob has the most rad names for his
moves like they're cheesy but that's
what make them brilliant oh and the fact
that they are all super strong abilities
too so he can call them whatever he
wants really I'm not going to tell him
otherwise so let's look at some of these
moves masculine has a technique he calls
star Flash in which he can project a
star-shaped laser from his mask he has a
crazy punch with an amazing amount of
force called the star murder punch a
black star forms on the back of his fist
when his mask is furious causes his fist
to become up to 10 times stronger and
release energy bursts in the form of
stars he has also referred to this move
as the hammer of Justice there are also
other awesomely named attacks such as
star Eagle Kick Star headbutt star
rocket headbut and star drop kick I
don't know why but I think they sound
cool I think you can just put the name
star in front of anything and it just
makes it more epic now what really makes
masculine a really tricky customer is
that he always has James follow him into
battle James is a short bold man who
carries a bell and he has a great deal
of respect for masculine and based on
what we know about masculin abilities
James is basically like a cheerleader so
to speak assisting him in amplifying his
abilities while in a fight now renji
eventually got the Big W over masculine
by defeating him and James but he was
certainly not an easy task to
accomplish next on the list is the
spooky sternritter known as the fear
whose spine chilling abilities should
not be
underestimated there is a lot to be said
about drowning someone in a deep pit of
their own fear a lot of people tend to
liken his ability to the Scarecrow from
the Batman franchise and yeah I I
totally get that as nod's abilities were
entirely centered on of course fear he
could keep people trapped in a nightmare
likee State simply by just staring into
their eyes his ability the fear forces
his opponent to lose control of
themselves and question everything they
do they lose all feeling of themselves
and are confronted with visions of their
worst fears in some circumstances this
has resulted in death as a result of the
person's heart stopping due to the
tremendous shock his Spirit weapon
consists of many Ry Thorns that float
near to him these Thorns are shot
towards his foes at high speeds impaling
them in a gruesome manner but this isn't
the reason we are talking about his
weapon yeah the real nasty thing about
his weapon is that his fear ability is
linked to the Ry Thorns he wields these
objects not only have enormous
destructive power but when combined with
the fear they cause his prey to feel
unlimited fear when they are struck by
these thorns TARTA forus which means
fear of God is the name of his V
standing his V standing has a menacing
appearance and is without a doubt one of
the greatest V standing designs in my
view his V standing of course
substantially improves his fear ability
rather than being penetrated by his
Thorns his opponent just needs to look
at him to experience the utter horror
and misery that his power delivers to
demonstrate how strong he was he was
able to defeat captain byya kuchi and
The sternritter Mask to masculine that
we just spoke about Rukia eventually
killed him but only after a fierce
battle which saw one of the most hype
moments in bleach in my opinion this of
course was you know the debut of rukia's
beautiful and badass bonkai so going
down to that definitely tells us that
asod was truly a very powerful opponent
and easily one of the strongest Stern R
roid Lloyd is one half of the very
intriguing twin Joo sternritter why also
known as the yourself we also of course
talked of Lloyd earlier his unique
shrift allows him to take on the look
memory and combat style of anybody that
he chooses making him a dangerous and
unexpected adversary there really isn't
anything else to this ability but that
certainly doesn't mean that it's one to
scroll over and ignore during the
invasion of the Soul Society roids
Flawless mimicry of UA was a noteworthy
moment that demonstrated this ability
and his talent with it his realistic
depiction of UA enabled him to hold his
own against none other than the
extremely powerful genri USA Yamamoto
the ghost High 13's then Captain
Commander this demonstrating his
tremendous talent and tactical Genius of
course the downside to his power is that
despite his exceptional mimicking
talents Roy's power is incredibly
dependent on the capabilities of the
person that he impersonates still even
after Kachi removed his iPatch roid was
able to overcome even the most
formidable opponent defeating Kachi with
his bare fists this was of course due to
the fact that he was imitating UA's
power of course which as we also
mentioned enabled him to stand up
against yamamoto's bonkai however
unfortunately for roid when his role was
over UA simply slaughtered him tough
break for this guy but what an
interesting
character next up we have the calm and
sarcastic Asin Asin is one of UA's shoot
Stuffle UA has appointed four
sternritter who are basically seen as
his Elite guard so this is definitely an
indication of how strong this guy is
Asin shrift is a pretty nasty one too
and it's called the death dealing his
ability centers around the control he
gains over the deadly amount of any
material that he drinks allowing him to
alter the toxicity of substances within
his opponent's bodies or the surrounding
environment this adaptable ability
allows Asin to weaken his opponents
adjust the efficiency of their attacks
or even completely disable them the
death dealing also known as the lethal
dose is a power in which asking can
calculate the perfect lethal dose that
will cause death on his targets without
fail using any substance he takes into
his body both rais and lowering its
value as he sees fit he then inflicts
that lethal dose to those around him of
course Asin must consume a large amount
of whatever it is he wishes to control
into his own body let's use blood as an
example once he has consumed enough
blood into his own body he can then
reduce the deadly dose of blood in his
opponent's body rendering them in a
fatal condition he's a very tricky
customer as he has multiple abilities
tied into his death dealing power such
as the power to heal himself by raising
his lethal dosage Asin can also develop
an immunity to substances or even energy
based attacks that he is attacked with
then there's gift ball which is
essentially a little ball of poison that
can knock out most opponents on contact
Asin can also stuff the gift balls with
things like nitrogen oxygen and even RI
he also has a horrific ability in which
he draws a bigger circle on the ground
forming an ominous area under his
control anyone who crosses the boundary
will be affected since he has the
ability to reduce that person's
resistance to anything this poisons them
with large doses of any material that he
so chooses looking at asin's Feats he
easily defeated Ichigo yiro yoruichi and
grimjow Asin would have even killed the
extremely powerful Ura Hara if he hadn't
been for GM's resurrection and Nel's
assistance defeating is one of the most
powerful and deadly opponents in the
series next up we have one of the main
characters in the series in uro Ishida
uro Ishida is of course an established
character in the series and we have seen
a lot of what he can do in terms of
powers and abilities however in the
Thousand-Year blood War arc our boy gets
quite the power up and he was even
regarded as UA's Heir his power now
compared to the beginning of the series
his very different and very impressive
like yet he was strong and all he
possessed his exceptional command of the
bow and his ability to absorb RI from
the atmosphere was topnotch but this was
really the case for most Quincy where it
definitely takes a turn for Udu is when
he finally gains the ability or shrift
of the anthesis uu's power anthesis
which translates to perfect anti setup
allows him to take any two Targets and
totally reverse whatever that has
happened between them for example if Ura
was severely hurt while battling he
could select both himself and his
opponent as targets and reverse what had
just transpired so that he would be
cured and the harm he sustained would be
dealt to his opponent which I think is a
really gnarly power and I definitely
think it's one that could be really op
if used correctly now U's holy weapon is
a light blue colored bow that is nearly
the same length as ULU himself it
features a smaller grip than his
previous bows and splits into a
cross-shaped configuration Udu also
possesses a light rain ability when
wielding this bow which allows him to
launch a barrage of arrows at his Target
in a second where he no longer needs to
visibly collect Rishi in preparation for
the attack so yeah ud's broad Quincy
technique repertoire along with this
exceptional command of archery and high
velocity fighting make him a combatant
to be feared although J's talents and
power are unquestionably impressive and
even with the title of UA's successor
his place amongst the mightiest Stern
Ritter is still yet limited by the
impressive presence of the other
sternritter above him on this list each
with even more devastating abilities but
still let's go for uryu for the
progression over the course of the story
man you'll love to see that you love to
see
that okay top five and moving on we have
a very big one and that is none other
than jugram jugram is the highest
ranking Quincy on the list he is The
sternritter Grandmaster advising UA and
serving as Emperor himself when UA is
sleeping jram is a very talented and
potent Warrior as UA's trusty lieutenant
and second in command he is very
committed to UA as well as being
immensely powerful and self assured even
declaring war on Captain Commander shun
curo Brave man that that's for sure
jum's ability is a really cool one and
also one that will sound very very
familiar jum's ability is called the
balance which is Japanese for World
Harmony it's very similar to udus and
nethis in that drum can absorb any
Misfortune that occurs within his sphere
of influence and distribute it to those
who have enjoyed Good Fortune similar to
ud's Ability if drug run were to suffer
any damage he can then take that harm
and inflict it on his Target who is
experiencing the said Good Fortune here
in this case this ability balances the
scales by combining their Good Fortune
with his bad fortune restoring the
equilibrium the fren Shield or sacrifice
Shield is jugram Spirit weapon jugram
can materialize the shield on his left
arm using RI which is not only
exceedingly strong but also highly solid
rather than functioning as a typical
Shield to prevent incoming strikes from
his foe The Shield also absorbs The
Misfortune that jugram would incur such
as the previously described injuries
jugram escapes most Blows By directing
them to his shield which he then
launches back at his opponent utilizing
the balance jugram is also the only
Quincy other than UA who can imbue other
Quincy with his own power he is also
unlike the other Quincy in that he
cannot naturally absorb RI from his
environment but may instead provide RI
to others around him jram also possesses
UA's power the Almighty which means all
knowing and all power powerful in
Japanese when UA lies asleep at night
the almighty's power is jugs to use but
only while UA sleeps this power allows
jugram to look into the future but he
cannot change it like UA can now Jam's
remarkable abilities are on show during
his bouts with BBY and uru Ishida as he
easily defeats both opponents in
one-on-one combat his abilities are
unconventional but not any less powerful
as a result however his combat with uio
was caught short by UA which resulted in
drum's death now you'd think that dram
would top this list being the grandm and
second in command and all however this
very clearly is not the case of course
it's not power alone that can grant you
such titles and drram had more going for
him than just power but in a list of
who's the strongest this is where drram
places amongst the sternritter and top
five is not bad really right next up is
pan another one of UA shoot Stuffle and
if you want to plain and simple why are
you on the list why are you this high up
well panita is also the left hand of the
Soul King so yeah extremely powerful the
soul King's literal left arm is an
unusual entity originally it was this
mysterious hooded figure its real shape
is actually a hand with eyes on the palm
really cool design if you ask me the
hand is very tall towering over Yumi
Chica and it during that fight Pena is
mostly mute and without personality
although other shoot stuff will
understand it it later did progress
however and began to use false speech
now Pan's ability is a really
interesting one and it's called the
compulsory the compulsory is a power in
which panita can shoot nerves from its
fingers that connect to the body of its
opponent once connected pan has power
over its Target's body via his own
nerves not only can he control their
emotions but he can also break their
body apart in a second if he so desires
panita can also utilize its nerves to
affect the form of non-living items and
its environment it employed this
strategy to assault its attackers by
spawning huge arms and hands from the
earth and structures now if one of Pan's
fingers is amputated it can use the
compulsory remotely where an ey appears
on the knuckle of the severed finger
it's pretty gross and unlike the
majority of sternritter panita and J
Valkyrie did not get any particular
powers from UA instead they already
possessed their amazing Powers
emphasizing their innate strength and
importance within the Quincy ranks
furthermore panita can adapt and grow by
absorbing its opponent's knowledge and
talents making it a very adaptable and
clever adversary the fact that panita
had this power without receiving it from
UA proves just how special a character
is and why they are set apart from the
rest bar of course the stone RIT placed
above them top three time and we have
one of the most powerful Quincy grmy
with what is not only one of the most OP
powers in Bleach but I guess you could
argue one of the most OP powers ever the
Visionary also known as dreamer bestows
upon him the incredible ability to
materialize anything his mind can
conjure up making him an extremely
flexible and dangerous opponent Gem's
creativity is his only restri ction
allowing him to do everything from
forging strong weapons and reshaping his
environment to regenerating his own body
for example if he imagines that his body
is stronger than steel then his body's
defense gains a significant boost and if
he were to sustain any wounds this
ability would be extremely useful if he
imagines that his wounds are healed then
yeah that becomes reality and his wounds
are then healed he can not only affect
his own body but he can also visualized
lava stone pillars water and other
elements to strike his opponent and
those materials just simply come into
existence he has the ability to conjure
weapons and even alter the battlefield
to his desire now gry's most powerful
ability is the ability to create life
gremy has the ability to bring his
fantasy into reality of course and he
used it on himself to make clones of
himself increasing the strength of his
imagination and allowing him to build
larger items such as a massive massive
meteorite gry's battle with Kachi Zaraki
demonstrates his tremendous might grmy
displayed a variety of skills throughout
their intense combat including the befor
mentioned Conjuring clones of himself
and even created a vacuum in space to
defeat his opponent it's gry's inevit
and unpredictability that make him a
deadly combatant nonetheless gry's
reality altering abilities are of course
limited by his own imagination and
mental fortitude this is where we get to
the downside of his shrift and why he
doesn't rank higher than third place
here it's overconfidence and an
inability to maintain concentration on
his own Creations that ultimately proved
to be his undoing if his Focus moves
away from his Target they will then
revert to their previous condition then
there is the possibility that his
imagination might actually deceive him
if he isn't careful he may
unintentionally Envision horror things
occurring to himself which of course
then become reality nonetheless grmy was
an incredibly strong opponent and it
took everything Kachi had to defeat him
taking the second spot is none other
than Lil Barrow who is the leader of
UA's shoot Stuffle he is confident in
his and UA's abilities yet he is often
frighten by things that he doesn't
comprehend he is the first Quincy UA
granted a shrift to and he believes
himself as UA's Masterpiece having the
closest connection to God can't knock
the dude's self-confidence and to be
fair he can really back it up his shrift
is named the xaxis which is also
Japanese for piercing everything and it
is an ability that allows his gun to
pierce through everything in his line of
sight his assaults are unblockable by
any Defender Lil can employ the x-
axis's full strength while both of his
eyes are open L himself stated that his
full power permits even his own body to
pass through opposing blows now the
xaxis also allows all opponent strikes
to pass through his body allowing him to
escape unharmed any time that he has
struck what's really cool about him is
that during battle he actually closes
his left eye because he feels his
strength is unfair to his opponents
speak about self assurance right and it
reminds me of Kachi and his eye patch
though to be honest it's the same way
Kachi keeps his eye patch on to keep his
spiritual pressure under control as to
Long out his fights due to his love for
battle it's the same principle here with
Lil except his reasons are more centered
around his self-confidence rather than a
love of battle however he does have a
rule if he does open his eye three times
during a battle he will then keep both
eyes open for the remainder of that
fight so it comes to no surprise that
his Spirit weapon is that of a rifle
going off what we discussed with his
power the xaxis his rifle is huge in
appearance and fires holy arrows or
bullets in this case that are strong
enough to completely wipe out you know
the cities surrounding the soul King
palace with just a single shot these
bullets are so powerful due to the
highly compressed Rae that they are made
of now Lil's V standing is known as
Divine judgment and it it looks super
gnarly to be fair the enormous feathery
white Ry wings are without a doubt the
most noticeable feature These Wings
provide him the ability to fly as well
as teleport his xaxis ability is further
strengthened in his V standing and he
can discharge beams of energy from the
holes in his wings at his Target if he
fires from all six holes at the same
time he has enough devastating Force to
take out whole cities in this condition
he is virtually Untouchable but it
doesn't end there Lil also has a second
Vol standing form that would regrow any
missing limbs he received if he would
was assaulted this form not only looks
amazing but it also has some nasty
Powers such as Ray of judgment which are
waves of energy shot from his wrists and
forearms he can summon a great ball of
light that erases all adjacent shadows
and he has a move called Trumpet Of God
in which Lil summons a massive trumpet
made of RI that fires massive energy
blasts of destructive Fury this guy is
just something else and the power and
destruction he is capable of unleashing
is nothing short of terrifying but still
there is one more Stern Ritter who
stands above him taking the top spot as
the strongest of all the stern R is
Gerard Valkyrie who is not only one of
UA shoot Stuffle but is also the heart
of the Soul King no combat with him is
fair because he possesses one of the
most powerful and insane abilities in
the entire series Gerard is is a huge
muscular being extremely strong and he
fights very aggressively he believes no
one can beat him when faced by many
lieutenants and captains he asked that
they all attack him at the same time
since it would not be fair to go
one-on-one and he certainly wasn't lying
here that's all I can tell you Gerard's
power is literally insane and it is
called the miracle like Pan the miracle
is an ability that Gerard already
possessed prior to becoming a
sternritter he has defined his power as
the ability to perform miracles on
oneself using ideas feelings and desires
so through probability manipulation he
is able to turn the tide in his favor if
Gerard is in a battle when the odds are
stacked heavily against him the miracle
permits him to Triumph regardless of the
circumstances he also possesses a crazy
Talent called damage empowerment which
allows him to transform any strikes that
inflict harm to him including Deadly
Ones into his own po such as strength
speed and even control over his own size
when it comes to manipulating his own
size he refers to this ability as God
size and the bigger he becomes the more
devastating his destructive power also
becomes his ultimate ability is linked
to one of his Spirit weapons hofn hnung
is a black double edge sword with a
v-shaped hilt and a star at its center
now the Miracle's final ability is to to
instill hope Gerard infuses the hope of
his opponents into his blade making it
nearly unbreakable any harm caused to
the sword is reflected and returned to
the attacker power of God is the title
of Gerard's V standing he obtains a nor
style helmet thick patterns on his arms
and golden white Heavenly Wings here in
this form he can shoot energy blasts
from the point of his sword that are
powerful enough to take out whole city
blocks Gerard possesses a second Vol
stand form in which his body can be
restored his helmet now resembles that
of a medieval Knight and he wears two
massive spikes on his shoulders Gerard's
Incredible strength and uncompromising
spirit were on display throughout his
battles with various high ranking
Shinigami notably Kachi Zaraki byak
kuchi and tosho heit aaya Gerard became
stronger and more powerful despite their
combined efforts and devastating
assaults continuously pushing ing them
to Breaking limits Gerard valkyrie's
tremendous power steadfast will and
nearly Limitless potential solidify him
as bleach's unquestioned strongest
sternritter and that is our list
concluded the stern R from Bleach ranked
of course from weakest all the way to
strongest what did you make of the list
do you agree with the ranking let us
know in the comment section below and if
you'd like to see more of our bleach
ranking why not check out our video on
the strongest characters in all of
bleach which is linked in the video
description and see if and where any of
the sternritter place overall if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more bleach videos on the channel make
sure to let us know by Smashing that
like button if you haven't make this a
video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
anime uo videos like we mentioned we are
so close to 2 million subscribers here
on the channel every subscription really
does matter remember you can also follow
us on Twitter and Instagram @ anime upro
thanks again and we can't wait to see
you in the next one till next time peace